well let's talk about the story here
ladies and gentlemen one man is standing
up and fighting back for all of us one
man and that man is Alex Stein Prime
Time 99 suing Alexandria ocasio-cortez
because she blocked him on Twitter after
he called her his favorite big booty
latina and this is what it says I'm just
reading the news guys he he said his
favorite big booty Latina on the steps
she got mad she blocked him he's suing
her and uh this is is this could be
interesting because it was previously
ruled Trump couldn't block people and if
you're a public official you couldn't
block people she blocked him now he's
suing her is uh is this the kind of
culture Warrior that we need right kind
of yeah and berserk I think Alex Stein
is really hysterical he uh we covered
this today at the post millennial can I
read you his comment about it read his
comments he said I love and care about
this country so much that I am able to
put aside my political differences and
try to come to the table with all
politicians especially AOC because we
align on more things than she probably
he thinks and I want to be able to
communicate to her through Twitter
because it's the modern day digital town
hall and political free speech is the
most important protective speech in my
opinion that was all I love one sentence
and then he said I love AOC and I hope
she can find it in her heart to unblock
me
oh wow I think Alex Stein actually does
really good work in that it is it it's
it's cultural it's fun he's not even
really conservative if you've ever
listened to his actual policies he's
been on the show he's fairly moderate or
even liberal in some regards but this is
the the reason why I think the story is
interesting anti-nasa if I remember
correctly yeah yeah
we argued quite a bit about how the moon
land about the moon landing he does not
believe it happened obviously wow okay
yeah yeah okay okay yeah a bunch of
globe tards out here that's what they
say of globalists globalists there's a
funny video where a guy does an
experiment there's actually 50 videos of
people doing these guys doing
experiments to prove the Earth's flat
and they accidentally prove its round
and they're like wait a minute how is
this happening one guy went on a plane
and he's like because the Earth is round
the plane will have to dip down every so
often to like you know to level out
which means If he if he films this
leveler you should see the bubble moving
right and then when he doesn't see it
happen he's like that proves it and it's
like dude does not understand how it
works gravity I've been in Planes all my
life man I've never seen a curve anyway
anyway
you know people are complaining about
Matt wall saying he's too mean
and I don't even think he was that mean
and uh seeing like Alex Stein he I Alex
Stein's like a one-up on Matt Walsh I
mean you could say Matt Walsh is direct
but Alex Stein like really grinds
people's gears like he he goes in front
of the protesters there are people who
hate him yeah oh yeah I love when he
goes in front of the protesters and he's
like Hi here's what he does here's the
technique
the importance right the important
component that people need to understand
about what Alex Stein does is that he
doesn't insult them he laughs says I
love you and he's too tall for them to
block so he holds the camera up yeah and
then he just starts saying I love you
you guys and he's smiling and it drives
them insane is one of the most brilliant
tactics so if y'all are concerned about
Matt Walsh we got out Alex Stein right
here but let's be real Alex Stein pisses
people off way more than Matt Walsh does
his tactic is more infuriating because
it's hard to counter it he's just having
a great time there's a there's this old
there's this old movie called A Thousand
Clowns anyway at one of the the kids he
says in the in the movie he says what
are you gonna do with someone who has a
wonderful time like that and that's
exactly what's going on with Alex Stein
what are you gonna do with someone who's
just out there laughing there's there's
some there's an issue on and and
speaking as like I don't know
the right or whatever there's an issue
on the right where people just want to
be boring they just hate fun they they
and it's it's been like that for a long
time
and I don't see that I had fun but but
I've read nothing but they're boring and
well I had fun with Jack we had fun yeah
I don't know about everybody else yeah I
speak for myself I had fun but I'm just
saying in general right there's this
there's like an aversion to fun that you
can't use fun tactics so we need we need
Paul Ryan up there talking about conch
to Medicare and Medicaid and Social
Security and this little remember this
bow tie act that he was look look even
even Turning Point USA's event was all
suits I think the only people who didn't
wear suits on stage was like me and Ian
and and I think I don't think Ben was
wearing a suit but like everybody's
wearing yeah everybody's wearing some
kind of dress-up well that's like the
uniform man yeah but how are you like
does that does does that image attract
young people
to to want to be involved in what you're
doing and I think not really it all
depends if your suit is like you know
like a lawyer's suit that's one thing
but if you're looking like you saw the
audience
that's pink and Periwinkle or whatever
and a big top hat you might a lot of
people are gonna be like really excited
there just need to be more parties at
these things more parties more events
McGregor looks great when he wears a
suit right like he's walking around all
you know they need to do more fun stuff
I don't know Keith for being fun right
they tried to go after him about that
you know I think you know being fun and
and doing music and trying to break out
of this look not for nothing but I've
been you know I I'm I have another job
where I'm in a band and we've been you
know allegedly we've been around for a
bit and I was putting the flag up in the
early part of the teens like hey I'm you
know into like Liberty and and I was big
on Ron Paul in 2012 and I was like
looking for conservatives that were
interested in talking about that like
about my band and stuff and nobody was
nobody was listening and the left hated
me because I was you know the left was
just as as you know as left as they are
you know so it's it's something that the
the conservatives and the right has to
get their act together on and it's like
when you've got people like the daily
wire and like Tim and stuff like that
trying to make culture the the other
like establishment right they're lagging
behind and they have been for a long
time
didn't Rogan just open a new comedy club
yeah a comedy Mothership I like that
name isn't it interesting how comedians
like I wonder if we can do in a wrestle
brand or like you go to the older you
know the the Norm Macdonald clips that
are coming out or even George Carlin old
clips will come out and it's it's like
comedians have this ability to tell more
truth and actually move the needle
better than
um Orion long when he does stuff uh to
move the needle and actually get this
stuff across better than well that's
like with the people on the right that's
like with Alex Stein right yeah and
that's what's funny like you're if
you're having if you're laughing you
know who else is going to come in a lot
a lot easier Donald Trump Donald Trump
is funny he's very funny he's a comedian
anybody who's ever been to like him
giving a speech he's doing stand-up it's
it's crazy
it's great he's great up there it is it
is like George Carlin was comedy with
some politics his is politics with with
comedy but like you're laughing the
whole time it's crazy and Norm Macdonald
one of his final interviews he actually
says that it's like I think with his
sister-in-law up in Canada and he was
talking about how he actually he kind of
catches himself so Norm is in is in the
interview
and he says he's like you know I I went
to see Trump at one of these great I
mean you know not not that I went I mean
I just I just want to see what it was
like right he kind of catches himself
before he just admits going to a trump
rally I love norm and he said um he said
but I want to give see him want to do
one of these speeches and anyone who's
been in the circuit knows exactly what
he's doing that it's it's a Basics it's
it's a stand-up routine he's he's
putting on an act he's got his material
and what's great for him is that so he's
able to use whatever's going on in the
news cycle can then feed into that
um and it was even better is that so the
reporters in these if you look at it
through that framework the reporters
become like hecklers and so they're
heckling him and the of course the
greatest one of these the greatest
exchange is is you know the the one
reporter and she goes he goes all right
yeah yeah you asked the question next
look at her she's shocked she's in a
State of Shock that I called on her and
he goes I'm sorry I wasn't thinking it's
okay I know you're not thinking you
never do
I went to that White House social media
Summit I was the only one not wearing a
suit in the White House oh really you
went to that yeah I was with Bill ottman
and my goodness I have so many questions
uh he just gave a speech and then we
didn't really do anything nothing got
resolved I thought there's gonna be a
real conversation like there's like
memes like posted up and stuff yeah yeah
yeah like Twitter posts like and tweets
easels and stuff like that it was really
funny and uh but we were just laughing
the whole time I mean he was doing
stand-up I mean one of my favorite
things is when he was like the lights
they make me look orange you know like
he just he knows he's funny that's a
huge thing with him though because he's
been doing media for so long that before
you do an interview with Trump he will
sit there and say let me see how I look
let me see that let me see let me see
the look do I look I don't like that
turn that light off the light turn off
turn this one on turn that one off wait
no angle this down he'll do all of that
because he gets it he gets how that
system works and he knows that image is
everything so I heard JFK Nixon debate
yeah the 1960 yeah exactly CPAC is
supposed to be the big deal and all I've
heard from people was that it was
stagnant it was boring not many people
showed up I had someone say that 10
years ago they went you couldn't you
couldn't even get a hotel room this time
they showed up like a day right right
before the event and there were tons of
hotel rooms available like nobody was
coming to it and that's kind of
worrisome I would say but there's got to
be well it's not an election year so
that's part of it still I mean there's
got to be some energy Something's Gotta
bring some energy into maybe a CPAC
isn't the answer maybe there's got to be
some kind of like
I don't know Coalition thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time